I was in Miami there was this homeless
guy living in a tent and I go up to him
I say hey bro do you want to be best
friends for the day and have some fun
and he's like sure and so we basically
go rollerblading play basketball do some
fun stuff like this and on the way home
he starts like kind of tearing up and he
goes dang bro like I was planning on
committing Sude and this like changed my
whole perspective on life I was like oh
my gosh like I had no idea I was just
having a good time like having fun with
you and I was like dang like I want to
see if I can raise some money for you
bro like to help you get off the street
like this is crazy so I made a gofund me
for him and he had raised like over 20
some 30,000 is for him he just changed
his life he went like towards South
America and stuff and uh it was just
powerful the first time I really
realized the power of the internet you
know to be able to crowd fund and stuff
was